a big problem when we come from a needy
place when we come from a place of
insecurity we start giving people credit
they don't deserve yet I just had the
most amazing date with the most amazing
person oh my God they're incredible
based on what
based on how on what basis what
information could you have possibly got
on one date that enables you to say this
you have been seduced by a kind of charm
Charisma maybe all of that is great I'm
not saying be inherently suspicious I'm
saying you don't know on what basis are
you giving them all of this value
already based on projection and based on
insecurity there's immediate putting
them on a pedestal and putting yourself
down here and when someone smells that
they don't see an equal anymore that's
what I mean when I say challenge I don't
mean artificially constructing games or
Hoops for people to jump through I mean
that the criteria you have for someone
has to be real